(audience cheers)
- Alright, we always
like to wrap things up with something
that could add a little
joy to your day possibly.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
Here's a little something for any of you
who get down at times,
thinking that love might
never come your way.
Just check out these newlyweds.
That's 93 year old Robert,
and 88 year old Anne.
They were both widowed years ago,
and never expected to marry again.
But then get this, I love
that they met on Match.com,
(audience chuckles) which is awesome.
Just looking for companionship,
and they recently told People Magazine,
It was head-over-heels
love at first sight.
I love this story.
We have these two on the line right now
watching on NBC4, New York.
Hello Anne! (audience cheers)
Hello, Robert!
- Hello, Kelly.
- Oh my god, y'all look
great, but congratulations!
(audience cheers)
I understand the wedding was
super special, right?
- Definitely. Yes, yes.
- It was,
- So people are looking
to you as inspiration
that it's never too late
to find love, fall in love.
So how does that feel?
- Gee, to be a model like that?
It feels like a big
responsibility, but a happy one.
I think the message I
would have in that regard,
stay at it, keep working at,
at Match.com or whatever.
It took me, I don't, hundreds of hours,
(both laugh) and so many
dates and phone calls.
So, stay with it and
you'll find your love too.
- [Kelly] Oh my,
- Don't give up the ship.
- I love it!
How about you, Anne?
- [Robert] I,
- Same thing?
- I hadn't even thought
about the inspiration.
My daughter thought it would be nice
if I'd find somebody to,
I was living with her,
find somebody else to talk to
besides her. (Anne chuckles)
So she said, Why don't
you go on Match.com?
I said, Okay.
It didn't take me very long because he, I,
he came buzzing through
and when I saw him,
I fell in love right, right on sight.
And it was, it was magical.
So that was the beginning.
Right? Love at first sight.
- I,
- And that should be an
inspiration to everybody.
- I too, the moment I saw
her, her photo, I was,
I knew I had to have that woman.
- Yeah.
(audience awws)
- Oh my gosh!
- This is my favorite one
I'm liking, oh my god.
Thank you so much, Anne.
Thank you, Robert.
(audience claps)
Congratulations! I'm
liking your post right now.
(heart dings)
(audience continues clapping)
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like y'all,
embracing every moment of life.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1000.
(audience cheers)
Just have a good time.
Oh my gosh, I love you both so much!
Thank you for taking the
time to be on our show!
(audience continues cheering)
And thank you to all our guests today.
Lena Dunham, Fortune Feimster, Ally Al,
Dr. Kathie-Ann Joseph, and Emily Kaufman,
y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, well try and change it.